March First Movement or Samil Movement refers to an event that began on March 1st, 1919.
On this day in Korea, the Declaration for Korean Independence...
...was signed by 33 brave Korean leaders...
...and was proclaimed publicly at Pagoda Park in Seoul.
After Japan took over Korea in 1910, they ruled Korea with intolerable aggression and brutality.
On March 1st, 1919, Koreans who were tired of their oppressive rule made an outcry for independence.
Numerous demonstrations for national independence erupted throughout the country.
The Japanese authorities trying to regain tight control reacted with brutality.
Many Koreans died, many were imprisoned...
...and many were left injured from participating in the movement.
Among those that died was a teenage Christian girl named Yoo Kwan Soon who was just 18 years old.
She was one of the leaders of her town and province.
Her strong passion and conviction inspired many to join in the independence movement.
Koreans did not gain freedom from this event...
...but the Japanese authorities loosened their tight grip and allowed Koreans...
...to write and hand out Korean literature and to gather and meet.
Japanese rule ended when they lost World War II in 1945.
March 1st, since 1949, was designated a national holiday...
...to commemorate the courageous demonstration of national spirit...
...and to remember the sacrifice of those who died and suffered for the independence movement.
Today, Koreans on this day distribute Korean flags and shout "Manseh"...
...which means "long live our country."